at this point do you know who you
actually have
available for today's game and what can
you share with us about
i guess the last 36 hours or so
yeah well the last 36 hours have been
nuts as you would um
expect you know being held up
obviously in new york you know doing
multiple tests waiting for tests
contract tracing um
then getting the list of guys being out
you know
uh getting back to philly at you know
one in the morning
um you know getting to your house
um then trying to think well not knowing
if you're playing or not
um you know on the phone with with your
coaches and stuff up until four in the
morning
um still not knowing we're just trying
to create some kind of game plan and
then coming here
and then you know an hour ago we were
told we were playing
um i think we're we have eight
active players um
you know one is one that's been injured
in mike scott that
i i can tell you now there's no way i'm
gonna play him
uh i just don't think he should play so
you can make a case we have seven bodies
uh to throw out um we had a walkthrough
that i wasn't a part of because i was on
a uh
call with the league and stuff so um
i have a list here that i've not even
looked at and
so of players and uh so
we're gonna throw them together and um
you know
the white howard is gonna play point
guard tonight and we're gonna see how it
goes
uh so let me ask you this even setting
aside the
the covid related stuff do you feel
i guess responsible or safe playing this
game knowing you're going to have
as you say you only have eight guys and
really it's like seven
with if mike is not able to suit up or
listen covet wise i'm 59 years old and
uh we have a 60 uh you know dan's older
at least i think he looks older
um you know um
you know listen i trust the league and i
trust the doctors as far as health wise
you know i'm not i'm more concerned with
health on the floor
you know we're going to play players
tonight that haven't played
a lot of minutes you know um i'm not
gonna
you know so like when you got seven
bodies if someone's gonna have to play
40 plus minutes and
so and that's not just for today that's
long-term health you know with
the accumulation of games you know it's
the numbers we want to stay away from
with our players
um so i'm actually more concerned
about that than i am actually about
covet
um and i am concerned about code but i
think
everybody is the league is and everyone
else is as well
um you know so yeah it's a lot of
a lot of stuff going on um
yeah next time let's go to keith next
good
kid hey doc i hear you said that um
dwight you know joked around said dwight
playing point guard so
the report that ben and joelle aren't
playing is true
yeah but it has nothing to do with just
not playing uh
you know ben was um in the brooklyn game
was
uh had some knee stiffness um
and so we almost probably knew after the
game that he wouldn't play tonight
uh and then joelle you know started
complaining about his back over the last
he
started yesterday and we didn't know if
he was playing or not
uh but honestly keith with the the
the minutes we would have to ask it
would be insane to play him
okay tonight so okay and and in regards
to to pious matisse and the other guys
with the contact racing
are you expecting them to be out for the
four or seven days
we don't know we don't know anything um
we um
that's we have to make that assumption i
guess keith
uh i mean they didn't have i mean they
were i think
at a table uh you know
so it wasn't like close contact um
so maybe that'll shorten their days you
know i don't know that i don't know
enough about any of this
um especially today i want to make the
statement that doc is a nickname
uh uh because i i clearly
don't know the medical part of this
whole thing i understand
i understand about three years going on
come on before calling you doc
the thing is so like basically because
from understanding they
the reason why they miss the game is
because those guys had lunch together is
that what it is
what the content is it's our team meal i
think it might have been our team
meeting
i don't even think it was lunch i think
it's practice uh
yeah and and but they are you know we do
the whole
like three at a table for the table with
the big tables
okay uh but i guess even that's not
that's too close i i mean i don't know i
don't get that whole part
all right all right thank you
raised hands we'll take these three guys
starting with rau quesner
hey doc uh really just uh two questions
based on
what i've heard from you do you did you
express to the league that you didn't
want to play today
just given the situation you find
yourselves in did you tell the league
that
and then secondly
i'm sorry can you say that again i don't
think we should um
but uh it's not for me to express
that i just don't think i just i do
worry about our player health on the
floor
and then secondly could you walk us
through the timeline of events on
thursday night as it relates to seth
like him
being on the court and the testing and i
guess there's confusion from our end or
at least from my end about how that
how that it's done the same way every
day you do you do your uh
um you know your rapid testing that came
back
negative um uh and then the big test
that really matters is
you know the nose the mouth the other
test and it takes a certain amount of
time for those all to come back
and uh right when we get it is when we
we
react and uh literally i guess
you know i was obviously out on the
floor uh but in the middle of the game
is when the report came out
and fortunately we have people stand by
to make sure right when that report
comes um
we react and so um
that's the timeline you know i i think
um
i was told after halftime about it
all right final two mark narducci and
then paul hodrick mark go ahead
doc when you said you were told after
half time how how hard was it to
kind of stay focused on the game that
you were you were coaching when you hear
this kind of news and there's so much
uncertainty
well fortunately mark you can remember
that game
it was pretty easy not to have focus
i guess but on a serious note it's funny
you said that i was telling joel and i
were laughing
about it because he saw me walk out on
the floor and then leave
and he and he was uh we were talking
about it today he said why did you leave
uh where were you going and uh i
walking on the floor i was told it uh
that
chef was positive and because i'm in
game mode i just kept walking i said
okay that's great
that's great news uh and then i walked
out and i stood there and it was like a
minute and a half like a clock and i
said wait a minute
they said positive and that's when i
walked back in to make sure
wait a minute you said positive
and they said yes and so yeah that's
that's when you uh you know you know
it's
yeah it's it's uh you know that you're
worried about him you know and
everybody else thank you last one paul
hendrick and then guys so you know we
got michael malone at 1 30 coming up in
two minutes so go ahead paul
hey doc that's my guys uh a message from
doc if
he can sit out about seven or eight guys
that would be
very nice of him hey doc uh
glad that you're safe and healthy but uh
just wanted to ask um
just you become really good with kind of
it seems like on the surface at least
kind of compartmentalizing stuff
happening away from basketball and then
being able to still coach and coach guys
but what is like
how how do you kind of do that today
mentally and especially you know with
the guys that you have
well i can tell you for me the first
thing you do
you coach them and you think about the
big picture um
paul and for me uh some of these guys
may help us
later you know and so they're gonna get
a lot of time
against a very quality opponent um
and it will be good for them the ones
who are playing
uh and so that's the way i have to look
at it uh um you know
tyrese max is gonna get a ton of minutes
tonight and
so um he's gonna see what it's like
carrying a team you know uh in the nba
and and what it's like where the defense
is now
uh they're focusing in on you
you know uh so there's a lot of
of that that you can learn and teach
tonight so
i will definitely be a teacher tonight
uh
more than you know thinking about the
score thank you
thanks guys thanks coach thank you